вийшло сьогодні доєднатися до нашої
презентації до нашого нашої інфосесію
присвячені комунікації цифровому
просторі
мене вже представили я Олена Міщенко
комунікаційний це бренду про вчег
і Сьогодні я розкажу вам як правильно
комунікувати простону компанію за
будь-яких ресурсів
у нас буде такий план ми з вами
швиденько познайомимося я розкажу про
комунікації не тільки для профтехів для
закладів освіти в цілому також поділюся
інформацією щодо наповнення і оновлення
сайту практичними порадами що доведення
соціальних мереж і окремо зупинимося на
копірайтингу тобто написання підготовки
тексту розкажу про корисні ресурси де їх
шукати і як ними користуватися і
фінальна в залежності від того скільки у
нас залишиться залишиться часу
відповідно ваші запитання
сесія триватиме приблизно 60 хвилин
теж
переключаю слайди
познайомимося
Мене звати Олена Міщенко і я вже 6 років
працюю у Digital Market і комунікаціях
мої основні напрями роботи - це
контент-менеджмент і маркетинг
соціальних мереж і із цікавого друга
вища освіта - це клінічний психолог і
тому він від роботи час я проводжу
власне дослідження Digital залежності
або інтернет-залежності як її прийнято
називати і веду власне наукову
діяльність отже як ви могли здогадатися
це буде доволі нетипова лекція з
комунікації А в нас хтось малює на
слайдах
можна це якось забрати будь ласка
це на жаль ніяк значить
расскажу я нажаль не вмію ще цю функцію
забороняти користувачам Але для того щоб
це по-перше це стосується тих у кого як
я вже казав смартфони планшети де
екран вони можуть Несвідомо люди це
робити він десь може там в кишені лежати
людина собі слухає в навушник і не
бачить що малює А щоб це зникло нам
треба зупинити шарінг екрану і
перезапустити shering тоді воно пропаде
от така трохи така трохи незручність
Так вибачте всі хто можливо потенційно
можуть це робити ми будемо раді якщо
вони будуть до цього робити тому що це
трошки зупиняє нас
видно
Добре
Отже враховуючи Мій досвід і освіту
бачите здогадатися що все буде доволі
нетипова лекція із комунікації
але якою була би типова лекція з
комунікацією Які би поради ви отримали
на ній по-перше вас попросили сайт як у
Apple але про бюджетах профчику Звісно ж
провести глибокий аналіз цільової
аудиторії навіть попри те що вас може
набути жодного досвіду також обов'язково
щоб ваш бренд був унікальний з великої
ідеєю і ключовими месенджами ви також
маєте співпрацювати зі змій з блогерами
з бізнесами бажано з усіма одночасно
публікуватися регулярно усюди особливо
тік ток бо в нас же ж молода аудиторія
всі соцмережі 3-4 пости на тиждень і
бажано щоб все було унікально на кожній
платформі унікальний контент
обов'язково Ви давайте рекламу у
соцмережах пошуковиках радіо на
телебаченні ну це так Нарешті від
розробки сайту будьте обов'язково в
тренді креативними і взаємодійте з
аудиторією проводьте конкурси публікуйте
інтерактивний контент і заохочуйте
аудиторію до спілкування
але що зазвичай з цього всього робиться
найкращому разі насправді ну 10%. тому
що це насправді
непідємне об’єм робіт для людей які не
займаються цим професійним об'єктивно
потрібно ціла команда професіоналів для
того щоб зробити це на високому рівні ну
і звісно великі бюджет
Отже моя вам порада щодо комунікації
розслабтеся
по-перше нео кожного про всяку кожного
закладу освіти є ресурси для комунікації
на максималках А по-друге якщо чесно по
секрету це потрібно зовсім не всім
для комунікації закладів освіти під час
вступної кампанії
потрібні всього три канали для
комунікації
тому що основне завдання комунікації -
це надавати інформацію прямо в ручки
цільові аудиторії тобто інформувати
це означає що вам не потрібно
заохочувати більше людей підписників
створювати якийсь інтерактивний контент
ваша задача в закладі освіти надати ту
інформацію яку шукає вступник і для
цього як я вже сказала ми виділяємо три
основних канали комунікації
Це ваш сайт ваші соціальні мережі і
гаряча лінія приймальної комісії
Оскільки сьогодні ми розмовляємо більше
в контексті цифрових технологій і
цифрових комунікацій ми будемо
концентруватися саме на сайті І на
соціальних мережах
Отже ваш пріоритет номер один - це сайт
Ви маєте його зробити максимально
зручним і інформативним для вступника
тому що сайт це ваше візитівка людина
якщо її потрібно знайти якусь інформацію
вона робить дві речі або іде гуглити Або
шукати якусь інформацію у соціальних
мережах
тому для того щоб людина легко знайшла
потрібну інформацію щодо вступу до
вашого закладу Вона має бути розміщена
на вашому сайті
тому розмістіть розділ вступнику 20-23
на початковій сторінці сайту щоб його
було дуже легко знайти бажано це зробити
так щоб це було перше що бачить людина
коли заходить на ваш сайт
також потребуйтеся про те щоб
розмістити там всю необхідну інформацію
яка буде відповіла на всі можливі
питання для вступника тому що особливо
молоде покоління вони не люблять
здійснювати дзвінки і коли вони не
можуть знайти інформацію в доступному
текстовому форматі вони можуть просто
піти
на сайт іншого закладу на якому це
описано більш зрозуміло замість того щоб
набрати номер приймальної комісії тому У
цьому розділі розмістіть все що
стосується документів тривалості
навчання обов'язково термін наступної
кампанії тому що вони відрізняються від
закладу до закладу правильно кожен
заклад вибирає їх самостійно і це
напевно перше що буде шукати вступник на
вашому сайті це коли саме йому подавати
документи
а також розкажіть чого ви навчаєте яку
кваліфікацію у вас можна здобути і
як можна вступити як проходить у вас
конкурс на відбір тобто щоб людина після
відвідування вашого сайту вже мала повне
уявлення про те як подати документи і як
вступити до вашого закладу
окрім того розмістіть додаткову
інформацію про наприклад співпрацю з
бізнесом або дуальну форму навчання про
стипендії тобто
додаткову інформацію яку може також
шукати вступник і Що найголовніше - це
перевірте що ваша контактна інформація
була актуальна перевірте що всі телефони
які вказані на вашому сайті вони були
робочими щоб на них відповідали
електронні пошти якщо вони вказані десь
щоб людина якщо напишене email вона
отримала відповідь звідти якщо у вас
немає можливості підтримувати це то
краще забрати або телефон або електронну
адресу а залишити тільки те чим людина
дійсно може скористатися для отримання
інформації і також перевірте щоб були
посилання на соціальні мережі саме на
вашому сайті щоб людина в людині не
довелося це Шукати окремо
де брати офіційну інформацію що
стосується вступу Я рекомендую
звертатися до першоджерел Тобто це
соціальні мережі і офіційний сайт
Міністерства освіти і науки України а
також Офіційні документи і листи від
Міністерства освіти і науки України Я
знаю що є багато медіа іноді великих
популярних освітніх медіа які також
пишуть про вступ про умови вступу до
закладів освіти але я не рекомендую а
використовувати це як першоджерела для
ваших матеріалів на сайті і для ваших
комунікацій Тому що
іноді медіа трошки перекручують Можливо
щось десь неправильно формулюють і в
результаті відбувається зіпсований
телефон чого краще в комунікаціях
уникати
і
[музика]
перед тим як перейти до соціальних мереж
дам декілька апарат щодо генерального
прибирання сайту
бажано до початку вступної привести його
до порядку до ладу тобто Перевірте чи
всі дані на сайті актуальні
Видаліть зайву чи застарілу інформацію
наприклад
запрошення на події 14-го року звітності
про конкурси 19-го року ви можете
залишити це в архівах наприклад але з
першої сторінки сайту це бажано все-таки
прибрати
і обов'язково перевірте щоб всі
посилання на сайті працювали щоб всі
кнопочки які розміщені у вас на сайті
ввели на існуючі сторінки
проведіть собі такий тест як наприклад
вступник який чекає інформацію приходить
на ваш сайт
і просто поклацайте подорожуйте по
своєму сайту перевірити чи все там
працює
наш другий пріоритет - це власне
соціальні мережі
це дуже важливо у наш час тому що я
думаю і ви також користуєтеся
соціальними мережами і вони вже стали
просто необхідністю дуже невід'ємною
частиною нашого життя
тому якщо у вас у вашого закладу ще
немає представництва соціальних мережах
Я раджу все-таки створити там прошів але
щодо комунікації У мене є декілька дуже
важливих порад
по-перше сьогоднішні цифровий простір це
суцільне хаос всі змагаються за увагу
користувача всі радять створювати
побільше контенту тому що
хочуть щоб користувач підписувався
слідкував за їхніми новинами купував
їхні продукт вони налаштовують рекламу
вони придумають різні заклики до дії і
атакують людей у соціальних мережах
своїми
підпишись прокоментуй навчись купи лайк
подивись і все це призводить до якої
реакції
стрес навколо і
ситуація у цифровому просторі вона теж
призводить до збільшення
стресу Тобто ми живемо в інформаційному
шумі і
це нав'язали шум додає до стресу від
війни від
катастроф від для таких це також стрес
світу випускних і спиттів
відповідальності за вибір навчального
закладу і майбутньої професії тиск зі
сторони батьків викладачів
це також стрес вступна кампанія і для
птаха освітян для освітян для батьків і
для комунікаційників Міністерства освіти
і науки України
тому для того щоб зменшити цю кількість
стресу і
полегшити життя і своїм оточуючим Я
пропоную вести комунікацію у режимі
турботи
це такий режим коли ми відмовляємося від
зайвого і тим самим спрощуємо життя і
собі і тим хто нас оточує
Тобто Це мінімальна присутність у
цифровому просторі і її особливо
перевага це те що є можуть дозволити
собі всім
тобто Вам не потрібно ламати голову на
новими ідеями для контенту
придумувати щось унікальне для кожної
соціальної мережі і бути присутніми в
усіх соціальних мережах писати ночами
пости і контент-плани терміново шукати
гроші на рекламу проходити купу курсів
одночасно з просування соціальних
мережах і в комунікаціях
це все не потрібно
натомість Я пропоную програму мінімум
обрати одну або дві платформи на яких ви
будете комунікувати
Instagram по телеграм я потім аргументую
чому
опублікувати там найважливішу інформацію
саме що стосується вступу оновлювати цю
інформацію за необхідності протягом
вступної кампанії підтримувати її
актуальність і додати трохи контексту
розказати про життя про птаху якщо на це
вистачає
ресурсів і часу
це все набагато простіше ніж звичайна
комунікаційна стратегія але ви можете
запитати А як же ж тоді регулярний
постинг і контент-план чесно Якщо у вас
є на цей час ресурси натхнення Можливо
якщо у вас є колаборанти у в обличчі
колег або студентів Хто хоче в цьому
також брати участь і створювати разом з
вами класний контент і просувати ваш
заклад у соціальних мережах будь ласка
Діти
разом із записом цієї презентації і
цієї професії і цією презентацією ми
надішлемо вам
дуже великий гайд щодо комунікації тобто
для тих хто хоче більше У кого є
можливість
вкласти більше і часу і грошей і
власних зусиль у розвиток своїх закладів
але насправді регулярність - це навіть
один пас на тиждень і вам не потрібно
намагатися слів слідувати
досвіду величезних агенцій або великих
брендів для того щоб бути присутніми
якісно присутніми у соціальних мережах
Тепер я хочу розказати більше про саму
платформи в яких треба публікуватися для
того щоб бути корисними саме для вашої
цільової аудиторії
Зазвичай щодо пріоритетності
рекомендують для молоді оскільки молодь
наша основна і найбільша аудиторія для
закладів освіти рекомендують
користуватися Тік током так і
публікуватися у тікці потім Instagram
телеграм і все інше але виходячи з того
що ми говоримо про комунікацію за
будь-яких ресурсів
ця послідовність і пріоритетність
платформ дуже сильно змінюється
на це є декілька причин перша причина -
це власне цільові аудиторії
саме у телеграмі і в Інстаграмі зібрані
представники обох цільових аудиторій які
можуть бути цікаві
заклади освіти і про втехом
безпосередньо
це і молодь і дорослий тобто і молодь і
дорослі користуються І телеграмом
Інстаграмом тобто якщо ми говоримо
наприклад про тіток то там переважно
сидить молода аудиторія підлітки і
молодь
20-25 років звісно там є представники
аудиторії старше але це дуже мала частка
той самий час Facebook наприклад це
аудиторія дорослих Там зазвичай ним
користуються люди віком 30-35 і більше
років
тому якщо ми вибираємо всього дві
платформи або навіть одну платформу для
комунікації під час вступної для того
щоб робити цю комунікацію якісно то
краще обирати саме телеграм і Instagram
у кожній з цієї платформ Я це не
зазначила але ви можете обрати як обидві
так і тільки одну і для вашої
комунікації цього буде в принципі
достатньо у кожної з цих платформ є свої
переваги і недоліки наприклад телеграм -
це надаємо можливість розміщення великої
кількості поселень не обмежена кількості
посилань і це Набагато зручніше тому що
в Інстаграмі ви можете розмістити
посилання тільки в опис і власного
профілю тоді як в телеграмі ви можете
розміщувати Посилання у кожній
публікації не у необмеженій кількості
телеграм також не примахливий до типу
контенту який ви там публікуєте тобто в
залежності від того є якими ресурсами ви
володієте ви можете публікувати як
просто коротенькі текстові замітки так і
в принципі
будь-який формат контенту фотографії
відео аудіо проводити добре І так далі в
цьому ще є додаткова перевага у період
війни тому що люди які проживають на
територіях де є перебоми перебоя зі
зв'язком у них можуть просто не
перевантажуватися картинки і відео тому
єдиний спосіб для них отримати
інформацію це власне прочитати її у
якомусь месенджері в якомусь каналі
тобто Текст - це один із базових і
найважливіших способів передачі
інформації особливо у сьогодення тому ми
пізніше набагато детальніше зупинимося
саме на тому як писати красиві і
чи табельні тексти
Ну як же як я вже зазначила телеграм
дуже зручний зручний і гнучкий
Якщо у вас є на це ресурси ви можете
використовувати його потенціал на повну
розробляти чат-боти додавати модераторів
проводити опитування взаємодіяти з
аудиторіями і так далі
але якщо ви спочатку їх немає ви можете
обмежуватися тільки текстами
Але у телеграма є також свої мінуси
наприклад там є така зручна навігація як
Наприклад у тому самому Інстаграмі
в телеграмі ви можете тільки закріпити
пост публікацію або додати хештеги для
навігації це не так зручно тоді як в
Інстаграмі ви можете розмістити текст
наприклад
тему вашої публікації на картинці і коли
Людина заходить у ваш профіль вона
одразу бачить що про що у вас на
сторінці написано
Але у інстаграма є
твої недоліки також наприклад це високі
вимоги до якості контенту тому що
цією соцмережаю користуються дуже багато
брендів всі бренди для просування і вони
вкладають дуже багато грошей для того
щоб зробити це просування
якісним класним і тим самим вони
піднімають планку якості контенту тому
щоб заходити в Instagram бажано все-таки
мати якийсь доступ до хороших фотографій
до якісної камери і мати якісь навички
обробки фото але навіть без цього
скільки наша основна задача під час
вступної це проінформувати розмістити
інформацію кишка вступник
можна використовувати Ці дві соціальні
мережі
за будь-яких ресурсів
і хочу дати декілька порад щодо
оформлення профілю у будь-якій
соціальній мережі яку ви не вибрали
будь ласка уникайте метафори гучних слів
красномовних виразів фразеологізмів тому
що коли Справа доходить до пошуку
інформації у людини зазвичай немає
натхнення і бажання насолоджуватися
красивими
обертами мови людина шукає щось
конкретне і Наша задача як
комунікаційників надати цю інформацію
максимально швидко зробити це доступ
доступ до неї максимально легким тому в
описі власних профілів Додайте
обов'язково назву закладу тому що це
саме те як вас будуть шукати І як вас
будуть відрізняти від інших Укажіть
основні напрямки навчання які можна
здобути у вашому закладі розкажіть про
основні переваги і обов'язково дайте
посилання на сайт Якщо є така можливість
то одразу на сторінку вступної
тут я прикріпила прикріпила приклад саме
профілю опису профілю в Instagram і це
приклад хороший як треба тому що тут
дуже коротко і ясно описані переваги і
особливості саме цього закладу освіти
може можете побачити що тут розміщений
логотип цього закладу написано отримає
першу професію це заклик до дії також
розказано що навчання і вступ без ЗНО
на базі 9-11 класів і також розкрито що
Цей заклад не тільки для школярів а і
для викладачів для тих хто шукає
підвищення кваліфікації а також для
дорослих і знизу тут є посилання на сайт
цей приклад можна використовувати як
орієнтир як має виглядати ви бачите тут
немає нічого зайвого немає мільйону
емодзі
якихось дуже яскравих слів
це дуже коротко стисло і дуже зрозуміло
тепер переходимо до контенту у
соціальних мережах що публікувати коли
йдеться справа про вступну тут не треба
дуже багато фантазувати адже наша
основна задача - це надати інформацію
актуальну свіжу саме для вступу цього
року тому розмістіть на своїх соціальних
мережах в принципі ту саму інформацію що
розміщена у вашому сайті тільки
дотримуйтеся правила що один постер
скриває одну під тему Для того щоб
людині було легше орієнтуватися але
легше споживати цю інформацію
на цьому слайді і на наступному я
розписала теми для публікації які бажано
розкрити у ваших соціальних мережах
в межах вступної кампанії ми не будемо
детальніше зупинятися на кожному з них
Ви отримаєте цю презентацію І це можете
сприймати використовувати як готовий
контент-план
окрім інформації про вступну Додайте ще
більш інформації про ваш заклад І якщо у
вас залишається якийсь час ресурси є
фотографії є відео Або можливо якісь
новини розказуйте про це також
за можливості знову ж таки
Ну і переходимо до дуже великого блоку
блоку підготовки текстів тому що коли це
стосується закладів освіти
є дуже багато
нюансів щодо оформлення тексту перший
нюанс - це
складність в тому що
освітяни працюють з офіційними наказами
з офіційними документами які є дуже
сухими і які для молодої аудиторії яка є
вашою цільовою аудиторією потрібно
спрощувати
тому я підготувала дуже багато порад
щодо оформлення тексту
одна із основних - це те що немає
сенсунового навантаження потрібно
видаляти замість цього краще додавати
практичної користі і конкретики
тобто замість того щоб поставити що у
світі є дуже багато цікавих класних
професій і якісь з них можна здобути у
нашому цікавому неулюбленому сучасному
закладі професійно-технічної освіти
замість цього можна коротко сказати у
порівнянні що робітничу професію зараз
не менш потрібні ніж іт-фахівці І це
дуже
влучним влучне порівняння тому що зараз
всі знають що ІТ фахівці дуже
затребувані і
вони користуються попитом
можна також додати що добувають здобуває
кваліфікацію слюсаря автомеханіка у
нашому професій і тут одним реченням
закриваємо цілих три питання для
вступника яку саме кваліфікацію можна
здобути чи це взагалі вважається
кваліфікацією і де саме Чи це заклик
професійно-технічної освіти Чи це якісь
курси це Чи це якась школа і так далі
тобто менше зайвої інформації і більше
інформації корисної
[музика]
друге рекомендація - це не
використовувати сленг
хоча дуже багато комунікаційників радять
все-таки
спілкуватися мовою вашої аудиторії але
якщо стосується сленгу особливо розмови
та з молоддю цього краще уникати тому що
якщо ви не використовуєте цей сленг у
повсякденному житті і не спілкуйтеся з
наприклад підлітками їхньою мовою у
реальному житті Якщо ви будете пробувати
писати нею вона не буде виглядати
натурально тому краще замість цього бути
просто зрозумілими
і
не звучить будь ласка як офіційний наказ
із Міністерства як я вже сказала молоді
Це буде дуже важко сприймати краще
спростити намагатися передати інформацію
дуже простими словами
наприклад ви можете брати насправді
публікації з офіційних джерел Да
наприклад соціальних мереж Міністерства
освіти і науки ми там публікуємо вже
спрощені варіанти особливості подачі
прийоми документів особливості вступу і
ви сміливо можете забирати цей контент у
будь-якому вигляді тільки текст або
разом з картинками і публікувати у себе
і це заощадить вам трошки часу
і остання рекомендація на цьому слайді
це не пишіть у стилі письменників
початку ХХ століття
скорочуйте речення одне речення Одна
думка коротка
не треба цілих абзаців з
переліками дуже довгими переліками і так
далі в цьому коротше тим краще
для того щоб перевірити наскільки
класний у вас вийшов текст наскільки
легко його читати і сприймати Прочитайте
його вголос чи легко вам вимовляти все
що там написано десь ви запитаєтеся
подивіться на цей фрагмент тексту і
виправіть його для того щоб в процесі
про читання і озвучки у вас не виходило
ніяких заминок або наприклад не вистачає
дихання на те щоб прочитати ціле речення
це також варто виправляти
також знайдіть слова які взагалі не
впливають на сенс тобто якщо ви видалите
якесь одне слово сенс не змінюється це
слово можна сміливо видаляти
будьте послідовними Одна думка перетікає
в іншу думку одне речення перетікає
наступне кожне речення
доповнює якось попередньо Те саме
стосується абзаців будьте
логічними не стрибайтесь із теми на тему
і будь ласка уникайте питань риторичних
і в принципі рекомендують не
використовувати особливо якщо у вас
немає такого великого досвіду саме у
копірайтінгу і комунікаціях краще
уникати запитань в принципі тому що
найгіршому разі це буде звучати як
питання у дитячому садочку І що це
означає правильно це означає що наш
профтех найкращим
ну і ще декілька порад щодо структури
вашого тексту
не публікуйте суцільним полотном Як
наказ Міністерства розбивайте це на
Абзац це
розвивайте абзаци порожніми рядками
додавайте більше повітря простору до
вашого тексту щоб він виглядав легким
старайтеся робити абзаци короткими тобто
2-4 рядки і 2-4 рядки - це після
фінальної публікації а не у вашому
наприклад гордівському або Google
документі також старайтеся писати
Короткі реченнями десь один півтора
рядки знову ж таки
у фінальному варіанті публікації для
того щоб підтримувати темп вашого тексту
щоб його було не нудно читати щоб він не
був монотонним чергуйте довжину речень
коротке довге довге коротке різні темпи
знову ж таки коли перед публікацією
просто Прочитайте цей текст вголос
наскільки Він цікаво звучить І
використовуйте емодзі на соромтеся це
вже щось дуже
звичне для будь-яких аудиторій головне
не треба з ними перестаратися не треба
їх тулити в кожному ряд ку і навіть не
треба в кожному абзаці за виключенням
списків У деяких соцмережах наприклад в
Інстаграмі
емодзі краще використовувати для
відмащування списків Ну як наприклад в
нас тут зірочки
на слайдах
А так в принципі одне однієї двох емоцій
достатньо на цілий пост так щоб ви
розуміли приблизну кількість
ну а для тих для кого ці поради вже
не дуже актуальні хто вже вміє писати
стисло ємко і так далі не такий
просунутий рівень можна додавати вже
метафори і якісь класні порівняння дуже
зрозумілі порівняння Які створюють
асоціації у вашого читача в уяві тут я
прикріпила два
пости з
соціальних мереж наприклад це як приклад
саме порівняння так подати до вдома
вечерю як в ресторані і У кожного в
голові після прочитання виникає своя
картинка як це подавати вдома вечерю як
в ресторані
і після цього Ми розказуємо далі да
наш наратив тобто
єдина платформа в цьому в нашому випадку
так і здобувають цю професію онлайн тому
що це доступно
або наприклад додавати щось робити ваші
публікації більш цікавими Наприклад
замість того щоб просто описувати якісь
професії ви можете їх порівняти із
професіями майбутнього і не просто
сказати професія майбутнього а надати
приклад що саме ви маєте на увазі щоб
людина з'явилася розуміння У нашому
випадку це на другому пості це були
Штучні інтелекти і вирощування моркви
вони вагомості
таке контент він сприймається якось
легше і його цікавіше чи читати Я думаю
ви за собою теж це помічаєте Але знову ж
таки весь цей слайд це для тих хто вже
вміє писати стисло ємко і зрозуміло якщо
ви ще тільки починаєте краще
сконцентрувати свої ресурси на тому щоб
звучати
приємний зрозуміло для вашої цільової
аудиторії
як я вже сказала Не соромтеся забирайте
наш контент до себе на сторінки
репостіть робіть скріншоти публікуйте
ми його і для цього теж створюємо Ми
будемо дуже раді якщо ви будете це
публікувати у себе тому що це яскраві і
дуже інформативні публікації
і основна ідея як режиму турботи так і
всієї цієї інфосесії це
виходьте із власних можливостей і
ресурсів
якщо у вас не вистачає ресурсів на
створення великої кількості якісного
контенту краще зменшить кількість
контенту ніж
створіть щось Що буде посереднє
якщо у вас є можливість створити більше
залучити більше людей до роботи будь
ласка
розвивайтеся креатив Та творіть ви
отримаєте ще один величезний гайд на
пошту Що можна робити в контексті
комунікації для того щоб зробити ваш
заклад більш помітним і як в цифровому
так і в
реальному житті
І що стосується ресурсів як і обіцяла
поділюся деякими інструментами які
спростять вам роботу
ви могли вже чути про таку штуку як чат
GPT це штучний інтелект або мовна модель
тобто чат-бот в який ви можете написати
інформацію і отримати відповідь
Тобто ви можете поговорити в принципі
про все і це інструмент можна
використовувати для будь-чого можна
питатися порад питатися рецепти А можна
використовувати для написання тексту або
для пошуку креативних ідей для вашого
контенту або навіть можна попросити
переписати цілий текст якось по-іншому
по-новому наприклад спростити або
написати у Тоні молоді так мову молоді і
подивитися на результат
Головне що стосується роботи із Charge
GPT це бути дуже конкретними у своїй
задачі тобто
надати максимальну кількість релевантної
інформації для того щоб отримати
класну відповідь бо якийсь підходящий
результат з яким можна далі працювати
тобто опишіть для якої аудиторії цей
текст від якого закладу яка мета вашої
комунікації Да наприклад проінформувати
або заохотити прийти до вашого закладу
на день відкритих дверей або заохотити
підписатися на ваш простір є ж різні
цілі комунікації Тому це потрібно
описувати цьому штучному інтелекту І
звісно який результат ви власне очікуєте
Що це має бути якого об'єму текст має
бути і Якою мовою
але єдина порада не надавайте якоїсь
сенситивної інформації наприклад там
назви закладів персональні дані
контактні телефони і так далі Це просто
потім додасте вже вручну
відредакуєте цей текст в межах
безпеки і на споживайте це як
безкоштовно джерело-контенту тому що
все-таки результат який видає чат GPT
він такий
більш-менш безпосередній його краще
використовувати для пошуку натхнення
ідей
написання
чернеток так драфтів
які все-таки потребують подальшої
обробки але обов'язково спробуйте це
дуже класна штука і може бути корисною
не тільки в контексті комунікації
також для створення графічних матеріалів
красивих картинок або навіть відео Якщо
у вас є на це час можна використовувати
два
дві платформи це канвар і фігма у них є
шаблони для картинок може зайняти якийсь
час звісно розібратися з усіма
можливостями з інструментами але вони
безкоштовні і Як тільки ви освоїтися а
це ну їх освоїти набагато простіше ніж
графічні редактори для професійних
дизайнерів і
за допомогою цих двох ресурсів можна
створювати дійсно красивий
привабливий контент для соціальних мереж
тому беріть те що на певпримітку і
спробуйте за ними теж попрацювати
Ну як я вже казала це офіційні ресурси
мон
соціальні мережі Instagram Facebook
Youtube телеграм
Заходьте туди Забирайте собі контент
Забирайте собі ідеї для контенту ми
тільки Раді
І наостанок
я вирішила поділитися ще таким
гаєм відомо щодо створення каналу в
телеграмі ви його потім перегляньте
детальніше тут всього 4 кроки
Я думаю що профіль в Інстаграмі створити
можуть усі але якщо навіть з цим
виникають якісь труднощі то просто
загуглить зараз дуже багато інформації
українською мовою
просто по Першому посиланню у Гуглі
і на цьому все Дякую вам всім за увагу
Сподіваюся це було корисно і я готова
відповідати на запитання
так друзі якщо у вас є якісь запитання
то напишіть їх будь ласка в коментарях
ми виберемо
ми виберемо їх зараз і постараємося на
якісь з них відповісти
так бачу тут запитують чи матеріально
надішлюють на пошту так і на пошту
надішлемо після завершення після
завершення зараз інформаційний сесії А
змістимо в
розмістимо вже на сайті І на соціальних
мережах протягом наступного тижня
Так тут є питання більш технічне чи
можливо розміщувати інформацію про наш
заклад на сторінках соцмереж мон тут на
сторінках соцмереж мон і там на сайті ми
більшості
розміщуємо таку загальну інформацію
Тобто
ви в праві там робити будь-що зі своїми
соціальними мережами Просто якщо ми
будемо там все розміщувати в соціальних
мережах монтоді просто
буде занадто багато інформації і не
завжди вона наприклад така от специфічна
потрібна вступнику
якщо до Вайберу чи можна ним
користуватися оце гарне питання Олени що
ви скажете
історія заплуталася в технологіях У
пошуках мікрофону да класні питання
насправді користуватися ним Можна я знаю
що навіть молодь ним користується власне
для комунікації що стосується навчання
так у школах У про втехах у коледжах це
такий основний засіб
обміну інформації Але знову ж таки Якщо
у вас є на це ресурси тобто якщо обирати
месенджер для комунікації я би радила
іти в телеграм тому що він по-перше
зручніший там краще інтерфейс набагато
більше функцій і
там є можливість створювати ці різні
канали Ну у нього просто набагато більше
переваг але якщо у вас є можливість
комунікувати і в телеграмі і в Вайбері
так будь ласка це теж класний канал
Дякую Тут є два таких коментаря і
напевно питання про телеграм цікавих
кажуть що
телеграм Не просувають ну тобто складно
є так розумію там там немає певних
алгоритмів просування і як з цим бути
щоб було доступніше для пошуку цього
телеграм каналу
Да це було у мене теж на слайдах що це
одна із таких недоліків один із
недоліків які в телеграму що у нього
алгоритми алгоритми просування
органічного ваших каналів немає
тому так розмішуйте цю інформацію про
ваш телеграм-канал на вашому сайті
наприклад зробіть кнопку з переходом на
ваш Telegram канал
доступною щоб вона була не видно на
місці щоб людина заходила і
могла одразу побачити що у вас є там
профіль і
залучати людей я дуже багато варіантів
як просуватися всередині телеграму ви
можете наприклад колаборуватися з іншими
закладами або з якимись іншими каналами
і розміщувати посилання один на одного
це більше вже так про DJ маркетинг так в
месенджерах але якщо казати про
обмеження якісь ресурси про мінімум який
можна робити це розмістити кнопку на
сайті і розказати
вашим студентам да або розказувати людям
які приходять що От дивіться У нас є
telegram-канал будь ласка Підписуйтесь
Ми там публікуємо там наприклад тільки
корисно і актуальну інформацію
Дякую в нас тут ще одне питання потім
току
можете дати поради по розміщенню
контенту в тік ток
А да Може
насправді текток дуже примхлива
соціальна мережа тому що по-перше це
відео контент чому я його і посунула так
дуже далеко тому що насправді на
розвиток каналу тектовці потрібно багато
ресурсів або багато людей які готові
брати в цьому участь да і які горять
цією ідеєю для того щоб розвивати тому
що по-перше щоб класно публікуватися в
тих тоці треба бути
користувачем Тік току треба слідкувати
за трендами трендами не тільки в темах а
й оформленні відео в звукових супроводах
відео так тому що
tiktok класна соціальна мережа для дуже
такого швидкого бурхливого зростання
тому що він якраз просуває контент
органічно без залучення якихось
додаткових ресурсів Але для того щоб
tiktok також контент Він має бути
класним Він має заходити ваші аудиторії
тут вже звідси витікає
висновок що контент має бути трендовим в
стилі платформи да динамічним це відео в
якомусь швидко змінюється кадри в якому
є якісь тексти надписи відео тобто таке
що привертає увагу і якщо у вас немає
можливості створювати такий контент у
великій кількості тому що друга другий
нюанс тіктоку це те що контентом має
публікуватися щоденно як мінімум один
пост на день для того щоб він просував
Ваш контент якщо ми говоримо саме про
таке динамічне безкоштовне зростання
тобто якщо у вас немає можливості
створювати такий контент то краще навіть
не розпилятися тому що скоріше за все ми
не буде багато
користі з того що ви полікуєте там
матеріали а створення відео навіть там
одного-двох відео на тиждень Це доволі
великий об'єм часу і ресурсів особливо
якщо немає досвіду
Сподіваюся відповіла на перше питання
Добре дякую Я думаю що на цьому Ми
будемо закінчувати нашу інформаційну
сесію от Дуже дякую всім учасникам ми
дуже раді що ви приєдналися і сподіваюсь
ми надали вам достатньо інформації щоб
ви потім користувалися своїх
комунікаціях
Так тут питання про те Наскільки швидко
ми відправимо матеріали ми постараємося
якнайшвидше вам відправити матеріал на
електронну пошту яку ви казали під час
реєстрації тому
Очікуйте
тож Дякую вам всім і будемо завершувати
Всім дякую що доєдналися рада була
поділитися своїми знаннями і Сподіваюся
це був буде корисне і допоможе
привернути більшу увагу до ваших
закладів і просувати про втехи в Україні